hello everyone and welcome back to
[Music]
game review today i want to take you
guys through
a game between one fabiano carowanna
and gary kasparov now this is a game
that uh actually sparked some
controversy back in 2020
the year of the online tournaments or at
least the first year of the online
tournaments
and today we're going to look at a game
that probably made gary kasparov
go raw anyways let's jump into it here
uh gary has white here and we're looking
uh with fabi with the black pieces
and the game starts with one c4 c5
b3 b6 now wait a second i may have
forgotten to mention something
you may have noticed something has
happened to all the pieces on the first
and the eighth ranks and that is because
this game
is from chess 9lx or chess 960 depending
on who you ask
uh and they are of course playing with
scrambled
starting positions with the only rules
being the bishops have to be of opposite
colors
and the king has to be in between the
rooks to allow for castling rights
now both players started off uh pretty
symmetrically as you can see
and that's something you'll see a lot in
chess 960 the opening moves the first
couple moves
really do tend to depend on the bishops
in many many cases
in this case the bishops are sort of
creepy and kettled or pre-developed
before the game even begins
so all that's left to do is open these
nice long diagonals for the bishops to
play on
and that is really the the nature that
of the game
from this point forward we're going to
see both players aim to activate their
own bishops while looking to not allow
the enemy to shut their bishops out so
gary continues now with knight g to f3
and we see fabi playing the interesting
knight
e to f six and uh it's a pretty
interesting decision here by the two
players bobby
actually i would say developing with the
less natural knight out to the f6 square
whereas gary using the classical knight
g1 to f3 idea
and the difference here uh i think is
that
fabi is actually getting the better end
of this deal here i think fabi saw a
little bit further ahead
with moving this e knight out to f6
because he understands
that the fight is going to be for the d5
square
white by virtue of having the first move
is already well prepared to play the
move
d4 which of course is very desirable you
want to
keep these pieces open and threaten to
lock your opponent's pieces out
whereas black may actually have to fight
for the d5 square
so why does this help fight for the d5
square well we actually
allow the g knight to develop out to e7
instead
whereas that's not a luxury this knight
on e1 is going to have
and perhaps we'll see that this knight
while it does have some natural
developing squares
is going to be in the way of whites on
pieces for some time here
uh in the game though we do see e6 by
fabi of course
we need to prevent this break through to
d5 which would stunt the light squared
bishop
gary continues now with king's side
castles this 97 move that i anticipated
uh well i didn't really anticipate i i
saw it coming because i analyzed the
game beforehand
um queen d2 by gary now knight g6 by
fabi
the d5 square is already firmly under
black's control and now it's just about
using the pieces harmoniously you see
fabi's starting to build up the pieces
on the king's side
both knights and both bishops starting
to stare down this side of the board
uh knight d3 by gary kasparov gary
continues the fight for the center
uh conversely now fabian continues with
queen e7
and we see both sides finishing
development here rick fd1
bobby snaps on the d4 square deciding
it's time
to activate this rook as well knight
takes d4
and finally king side castles so this is
the first moment when i want to stop
out of the opening and sort of assess
how this has
gone so intuitively it looks as if
white's pieces are a little bit more
centralized so you might expect white to
have some kind of advantage here
however i do think it's actually black
with the advantage for the moment black
has not given up
the d pawn for the c pawn as white has
and this
is actually going to give black a little
bit of extra leeway
in the center there's also a very very
surprising break that you might not
anticipate
that black is able to think about here
and that is the break of potentially
pushing e5
and e4 and like i said uh it's going to
be about the bishops here and if black
is able to achieve
these kinds of moves then these bishops
are going to feel a little bit
lackluster
looking at the the strong pawn that is
also kicking away these knights
from their very strong outposts in the
center for example
e5 the knight moves around a6 the knight
has to come back
and then all of a sudden both bishops
are staring at their own knights
and this diagonal is a little bit
blocked off as well meanwhile black
always has opportunities to push the
pawn even further with things like e4
and e3
and still great attacking prospects on
the king's side
so fabi i think definitely got the
better of gary out of the opening
but we'll see that gary is actually able
to start turning things around here
in the middle game so how do we start
with that
well gary perhaps realizing that there
is some tension happening on the king's
side with these bishops
staring down and the queen ready to
launch in behind the knight
so he offers a trade of the queens which
uh prompts fabi to decline with tempo
with bishop d6
and this also prompts gary to retreat as
well
so kind of a slight uh maneuvering game
going on here for a moment
basically gary draws out fabi's bishop
to the d6 square a square where it's not
very comfortable
opposite of rook and uses this
opportunity to reroute the queen to a
more active post
fabiano continues with rook f to e8
perhaps anticipating these e5
e4 bricks and now we see knight b5
by gary this of course hits the bishop
here
and increases the pressure so fabi
simply retreats
and now we're going to see uh what could
have been the the fatal mistake of the
game by gary which is the move queen b4
once again offering this queen trade
this time with the idea that bishop d6
is not going to be playable
and this i think really is the the move
of the game here this is where
fabi goes from having some kind of
advantage to a completely level playing
field in my opinion
and the problem is fabi missed actually
a winning idea
that many of you are probably familiar
with at home so if you want to pause the
video here
find black to move and win go ahead and
take that chance
but here's the solution bishop takes h2
it's the prime opportunity
for the greek gift sacrifice this king
with all of these three pawns still on
their starting squares
really has no escape route through to
the center and
due to that knight g4 check is is simply
going to be crushing
the king comes back home queen out to h4
and there's no way to deal with the
threat of queen h2
you might expect that you can play the
move queen d6 but then e5
locks this queen back out of the game
similarly there's no bishop to e5
ever because the knights do well to
cover that square
so white is is simply busted here now
what was stopping black from doing this
earlier
well uh gary actually had the right idea
with this queen on c3
so if fabi were to attempt something
like this a turn earlier
then king g1 queen h4 in the nasty move
knight f3
is making a lot of threats at the same
time no time to take this knight off the
board to renew the threat
because queen takes g7 is immediately on
the board
so fabi perhaps missing a winner there
with bishop takes h2 in this position
that being said he chose d6 instead
keeping the position alive
but after d6 like i said the character
of the game is about whose bishops are
more active
and after d6 black is sort of playing
ketchup in this regard this bishop on v8
looking a little bit stuck the game now
continues with f3
gary looking to take over the center a
little bit more keeping this knight out
of any of these nasty squares that we
were talking about earlier
now a6 forces this knight back to d4 a5
takes more squares on the queen side and
we see gary retreat back
to e1 now once again fabi perhaps has a
slight positional edge here
because he is able to manufacture the
move d5 and once again
it's all about the bishops white's
bishops still looking at these knights
and black's bishops
ready now to open up at a moment's
notice
c takes d5 played in the game now knight
takes d5
and we get a trade of rooks rook c won
by gary
and now the game starts to slow down a
little bit with the open c file
uh not the only open file on the board
but really the only usable open file as
the d
file is so clogged now we're going to
see some major pieces fall off the board
and the game sort of steer towards more
level territory
all right so we get knight c6 played in
the game gary
realizing that he needs to activate
these bishops uses this opportunity to
actually take one of black's bishops
and increase the pressure on the c file
meanwhile fabi is not giving up on this
king side attack
activating the queen with queen g5 now
g3
by gary is the defensive move to keep
sort of all of these threats at bay
things like knight e3 were starting to
to be in the air
and then we see fabi once again take a
wrong turn we've sort of had this back
and forth struggle
in the game where gary was trying to
actually sort of re-equalize
out of the opening uh and fabi uh misses
the the key opportunities to really
seize an advantage so
what was the advantage for fabiano in
this case
well he actually missed an opportunity
to really plug up
all of the weaknesses in white's
position and
black could have done this here with the
move knight g to e7
so not a natural move at all sort of a
move that looks as if
it's heading in the wrong direction
right you want to increase the pressure
on the king side you want to attack on
the king's side
but the point of it is actually very
concrete you force white's rook to move
white's rook doesn't have too many
places to go
let's say it heads to the c2 square now
we plant this knight on e3
this knight on d5 and these are two
unassailable knights that can never
really be driven away this night
a huge thorn in white side meanwhile
these threats are always in the air
and fabi's idea uh of h5 and h4
definitely could be seen at a later date
but these nights
really really powerful pieces and could
have been improved to the maximum here
for fabi
meanwhile fabi actually decides to play
this move h5
which again makes a lot of sense but
it's just not going to be working
uh quite fast enough yuri uses this
moment to take back control
uh over this diagonal with queen to c1
now these knight e3 plans are a little
bit less convincing
uh as the b6 pawn number one is hanging
and number two the knight is already
under some pressure
so we see queen e7 instead now rook c8
and gary says let's trade off a few more
pieces
uh h4 by fabi is trying to create
some more weaknesses in white's camp and
then gary has a pretty instructive
response here
facing these two attackers uh on g3
the answer gary actually comes up with
is to put more pieces on the dark
squares
with the move uh f4 and this is a great
move to actually stunt this bishop and
reduce its influence a little bit
it seems weird to defend the g pawn by
making the g
pawn you know sort of critical to your
position right you need this g-pawn to
defend f4 now
but this is actually an effective way to
block out the attackers
against g3 from here fabi tries to
activate a little bit with bishop d6
gary now starts to invade with queen c6
and the tide is definitely turning once
again
we see queen f8 by fabi trying to regain
control of the eighth rank
the rooks come off the board
takes takes now queen c4 by gary
and all of a sudden the attack on the
king's side sort of seems to be
faltering
meanwhile these two bishops have been
sort of lurking
back here for the entire game and their
influence is going to be felt pretty
soon here
and gary also has quite a mobile center
with this e2 pawn
ready to launch forward at a moment's
notice so bishop f8 played in the game
trying to activate the queen
now we see bishop d4 and like i said
these bishops now
springing into the game and h3 by fabi
is going to be sort of the move that
gives gary a a pretty decisive edge here
uh fabi uh perhaps in the rapid time
control was looking
to uh get some cheapos perhaps on the g2
square
but this h3 pawn is actually one step
too far and
gary finds the right idea simply knight
f2 and this pawn is indefensible
gary just going to go up a pawn now and
this h pawn was actually one of the most
important attackers
for black without this h pawn it's going
to be really tough to make any concrete
threats against this white king
b5 played in the game for uh
fabi and the point here is that if white
captures on b5
we do have a small little tactic like
this whether or not this tactic is is
even all that good is up for debate
but uh gary chooses chooses the more
simple approach of just queen back to d3
now knight b4 is trying to activate once
again
queen out to e4 now a lot of pressure on
this diagonal as well
uh queen c7 and gary simply picks up
this pawn
now uh fabi plays the move knight d5
and gary uh to his credit also
misses a win here as bobby had had been
missing
for a couple moves earlier so now
gary did have the move f5 uh taking
advantage of the fact that this pawn is
a little bit overworked
uh and uh
this move just would have been really
strong it really breaks down
black's entire position black of course
is missing the light squared bishop and
so is relying on these two pawns to
guard all of the light squares
and once these pawns start to tumble
then there's really no recovering
for example f5 there are some
complicated tactics here with queen c1
check and he takes f5
but we're not really interested in
taking the the knight and hanging our
bishop
we just want to loosen these light
squares and gary would be absolutely
crushing
in this position so instead of that
gary chose the simple move again queen
d3 and now after bishop c5
we get the moment of controversy for the
game of course this was an online event
in 2020 uh and here gary
uh had an unfortunate and rather unusual
type of mouse slip if you can call it it
wasn't exactly a mouse lip
it was more of a pre-move debacle
so gary um had actually
tried not to play the strange move queen
d3
gary had attempted to play the much
better move queen c2
queen d3 uh does look a little bit odd
allowing things like queen c1 check and
ideas of this nature
so gary had actually attempted to play
queen c2
fighting for control of the c file
trying to get down to an end game where
the bishops will be even more powerful
and instead the queen landed one square
short
on d3 now that's bad enough that's bad
enough but
not all is lost white still has a good
position until you realize
that gary had tried to correct his move
of queen d3
by placing the queen on c2 again
inadvertently
gary had pre-moved queen to c2
and after this bobby actually chose to
play bishop c5
rather than queen c1 then gary's
pre-move was enacted of queen c2 which
of course
undefends the bishop with check and gary
was forced to resign
the game so not quite your typical mouse
slip here
with gary missing queen c2 with the
typical mouse slip but then
even worse uh creating an inadvertent
pre-move
and this is how the game had ended so up
to this point
a really really interesting struggle uh
relating
to the center of the board and how the
bishops were playing against each other
uh but then the unfortunate end gives us
uh the controversy of the tournament
basically where gary
had the big mouse slip and i i think was
seen i don't know throwing some things
at least shouting
on the webcam we we got to see always
fun to see gary competing
with those emotions although we do
prefer when those emotions are because
of the chest actually being played and
not because
of the mouse mistakes uh anyways
that's it for today on game review as
always my name is caleb denby
and i will see you next time
you